my name is Peter Santaniello and I make
videos around the world but for the
first time I'm showing my home country
America in this video series my
Ukrainian wife and I travel through
Northern California to places most
foreigners and even Americans don't know
about we will show you USA culture
through the combination of an outsider's
and a locals perspective
join us on a road trip through a very
diverse often misunderstood and
stunningly beautiful land it's really
cool when you come back to your country
after being gone for a long time here on
the edge of San Francisco today I'm
gonna show you all the cool
neighborhoods of this great city and the
city small it's only seven miles by
seven miles which is like 11 kilometers
by 11 kilometers but it has so much in
it so many different so many different
cultures so many different neighborhoods
so many different climatic zones bit fog
you right now hopefully this lifts
from here GTS and natalia's been talking
about San Francisco reminds her of GTA
in that foghorn
that's so the ships you know who where
the land is because they can't see the
light in the fog
a little secret deviation off the path
it's pretty much always windy here in
San Francisco and you can see the fog
lifted and that's how it works here the
it's like a natural air conditioner this
is the bay under the Golden Gate Bridge
and they're crazy turbulent waters in
there because the bay is quite huge and
the ocean currents are going in and out
it's not somewhere you'd want to swim
but you can see the fog getting pulled
in like an air conditioner and then it
goes out and it goes it rains only comes
in the winter so this plant life
survives off the fog these deep veins
like where the fog lays in and there's
red there are redwood trees or cypress
trees all different plants but the
climatic zones even in the city this is
what's super interesting even in this
very small City depending on where
you're at where we started it's very
cold and what we're going should be
quite warm this is the Sea Cliff
neighborhood my opinion one of the nicer
ones beautiful mansions overlooking
China Beach Baker Beach quiet part of
the city over here I lived not far from
here and I like this part of the city
the weather is colder there's more fog
but I think it's more beautiful so for
my international audience that doesn't
know how America works these homes here
say the person owns it outright no
mortgage owns the home they still have
to pay taxes and heavy heavy taxes so
you know for example a home pay done all
right a lot of German tourists the home
we just passed you know maybe it's 40 50
60 thousand dollars a year in taxes and
that's when you own the place so you
can't just buy a house in America a very
beautiful expensive house and call it
yours in a way you can but stop paying
taxes
and see who owns the home the government
will take it very quickly without
hesitation it's in a way you never owned
your home because in Ukraine you don't
pay taxes on Homestead I think it's very
small amount this is the new mega money
here mega money Jack Dorsey if Twitter
lives in this neighborhood I'm sure
they're a bunch of people that everyone
knows that live in this neighborhood
check out this one there look at this
place it's so beautiful and these ones
on the water you just can't see what
they are but I'm sure they're over the
top I'd say what are the cool aspects of
the u.s. is not all the mega money is
blocked off meaning these aren't like
all behind castle walls I mean some of
this stuff is walled in but in a lot of
parts of the world when you have you
know all these people are mega
millionaires for sure usually that's
behind a gate in security and while I'm
sure Jack Dorsey and others have
personal security a lot of these people
don't and I think that's the cool aspect
of the culture I gotta say so fuel these
neighborhoods feel them they all have a
different feel to them seriously this
isn't relaxed chilled out sort of vibe
right yeah it is Sunday
so no one's on the streets but you can
tell there's not there's no hustle and
bustle over here let's get to this
farmers market big thing on the weekends
are these farmers markets and people
come in from the outlying areas
California is great for food because
it's a good growing region and there's
this huge food with food movement with
organic foods and so you get excellent
cheese eggs meat vegetables fruits and
these farmers come into the city on the
weekends and so not all McDonald's
America that's for sure it's so many
people I have to explain to that leave
me abroad and traveling abroad making
movies abroad McDonald's is all about I
mean a u.s. is all about fast for you to
like yes and no there's parts of it that
are like that's those are the options
and then there parts like here where no
it's not that low level stuff to other
countries right
and all this change and
just like your associate America is this
stuff because you don't see anything
else like I know from you that you it
has to here in California uses a lot of
healthy people but you don't really
associate America this difference in
your gray but that school is you leave
all this processed stuff and the best
stuff for your song I don't know if it's
true or not but for example it's an
expensive choice I think healthy food
cost money and so when you go to Ukraine
right McDonald's is you know almost like
oh we're gonna go to McDonald's we're
gonna go to something that's nice almost
even though that's not the nicer
restaurant in Ukraine and keep there are
sweet nice restaurants but there's this
perception that it's like the nice thing
right and here it's like me don't have
much money you're on a budget the fast
food is the cheap stuff
but also you don't see a lot of people
a lot of people live to house their
lifestyles you sort of want to comply
with them maybe
yes so so the interesting part about
that is Natalia's only seen the nice
part from the coast into the nice
neighborhood and so we're gonna see if
surprise you're gonna see some
differences coming up here okay for sure
what do you think they're a little
different on the streets Renaissance
yeah boom yeah
the goodwill I used to drop all my used
clothes here
here it is ninth and Clemente my old
place I used to park the motorcycle down
here and definitely some nostalgia for
this place I didn't go here much but we
had this beautiful library
look at the ceiling babe
cool architecture in the city America's
not the best for architecture their
cities with great architecture but it's
not old right it's not Europe but you do
see a lot of interesting stuff here like
that ceiling in this city Surrey used to
go for my fruit fish anything Asian
interesting huh yeah
I always found a little bit of irony in
the sign here the Bank of America with
the Chinese letters over it this was
basically sand dunes this part of San
Francisco it so roughly 130 is years ago
something like that
[Music]
cool thing about this neighborhood is it
still a community they still have the
local Baker that's been around forever
they have the the cobble Smith the local
restaurants that have been here forever
a little hole in the wall places here's
a very famous bookstore it's a two story
bookstore and as much of San Francisco
is one of the way of gentrification I'd
say this neighborhood has kept quite
original
we got too excited exploring the cliffs
and the parks but this is a farmers
market I want to show you the farmers
market on the weekends quite popular
this was closing up obviously there I
think they're like 10 10 to 15 of them
in the city every weekend fish tacos
[Music]
stop the neighborhood for Mexican kids
but I was dying for fish tacos what do
you think of the food in the u.s.
[Music]
excellent
okay
Tilly eat your dog now in Golden Gate
Park the city's flagship park I would
say and we have some cool buildings in
here the Academy of Sciences over there
it's got like a natural roof to it a
grass roof this is Twin Peaks up here
this is a forest full of eucalyptus
beautiful forest up there and then the
DeYoung go see a nice modern looking
Museum here it's the biggest park in the
city the most beautiful park in the city
in my opinion it's got a little bit
everything Sundays they close the main
road down
[Applause]
[Music]
but see that sound system yeah yeah
that's provided by this guy named Davey
Davey someday just come D
[Music]
we just came in here and just walked
this little bit babe check that out but
its massive look at all this there's
even a polo field there are Bisons down
here Golf Course yeah we saw in the car
this is a park for sports for activities
for getting outside and Ukraine it's
more of Ukraine it's more of hang out
with some friends drink some coffee
right dress up this is where your
sweatshirt play some volleyball get on
some wheels whatever those are
what's going on here
it's an amazing drink isn't it it's
carbonated it's got mushroom in it it's
tea but it's got a very flavour super
healthy low on calories
[Music]
this is the 8th district and fake corner
of the counterculture 60s hippie
Grateful Dead experimental drugs
movement started here anti-war movement
started here and it's continued to this
day this hippie alternative whatever
goes
[Music]
and wait to see if her yeah Thank You
Brad who would walk in I knew we told my
mother I'm not would yes this is the one
this is the one you don't have to have
you canvas course it's like buying
alcohol exactly yes
[Applause]